[Music]
hello there are you tired of using
tokenizers for your language
transformers
highly likely you're not because usually
these lines from the hugging face
library do the heavy lifting for you so
you usually do not care about
tokenization but
tokenization is a pre-processing step
therefore it is rigid
and not adapted to your application nor
your data but wait no more
charformer is here enabling end-to-end
language transformers that do not
require tokenization anymore
miss coffee bean are we cool you know
what happened in our last video
and i only wanted to know if we're okay
now
yes cool tokenization
is that part in pre-processing that is
done
to text before throwing it into your
favorite language model say
bird it is a pre-processing step so
it is independent of the later training
process
but it's crucial for most transformers
without organization
each word of the english vocabulary
would have to be assigned a unique
vector
on the input side and when predicting
the massed word in the output
the choice would have to consider the
whole vocabulary
and if you believe that the english
vocabulary that one can find in a
dictionary
is already huge think about how it can
grow
even faster with all words that are not
in a dictionary like compound words
created on the fly by someone as a
stylistic figure
or all possible typos right
a mistyped word is also a word and
should have a way to be processed by a
language model
this is where tokenization comes in to
at least
partially solve this problem by creating
a smaller vocabulary
of word building blocks this hopes to
cover as much of the dictionary as
possible
including unexpected words therefore
tokenizers first segment the sentence
into words harder for some languages
than
for others i'm looking at you chinese
thai and korean because you do not have
white space separation
then the words are parsed into sub words
so that even though
supposedly the dictionary does not have
the word
pre-processing in it and therefore no
vector representation to associate with
it the tokenizer can divide the word
into pre and processing supposing that
pre and processing
are already in the vocabulary and have a
vector association
and this works great in very regular
kinds of worlds that can be decomposed
into known blocks but
does not solve the problem of noisy text
full of typos where the possibilities of
mistyping are
so many that a fallback to a known sub
word is either
impossible or leads to misunderstandings
so tokenization being so rigid can
become a problem an even bigger one
when working with multiple languages
where the auto vocabulary
problem becomes even greater with every
additional language the model has to
handle
even more the downside of tokenization
is that on
downstream applications you are kind of
forced to use the same
tokenizer as the model was trained with
because the trained model is
very much dependent on the tokenization
it is used to
even though your task might benefit from
other tokenizations you
now must stick with the initial ones no
you're not allowed to see
other tokenizers miss coffee bean here's
where the char-former
comes to save the day what if you would
have a completely
end-to-end language transformer that
does not
require this tokenization pre-processing
step
and takes the data in as is in
characters
and dynamically computes fitting
representations
for your tasks and data on the fly but
miss coffee bean
wants to know why do we need a char
former in the first place
what if we would take in the characters
give them
all an initial vector representation and
throw
them like that into the transformer and
boom i mean problem solved where is
coffee bean it is not that easy
on the one hand it is exactly what
related work does but that also means
that
the sequence length for the transformer
would be the same as the number of
characters
this can be a lot which increases
computation
and memory complexity significantly
therefore the tranformer enables faster
pre-processing
of raw character inputs by dynamically
tokenizing the characters
into sub words then feeding the
tokenizations into a transformer
and training everything jointly so
tokenizer and transformer at once hereby
it achieves the flexibility of
other character level models but does
not blow up the sequence length because
it learns a tokenizer which reduces the
sequence length on the fly tokenization
with gradient shakaboom
nice so great now that we know what
happens high level
let's see under the hood every time the
authors say character
they mean bite because this is how they
encode each character allowing them to
work with
many languages where all language
characters are all encoded in this
byte space so the idea is to have your
input which is a sequence of
l characters each encoded by d
dimensional vectors here
eight-dimensional
bytes and the goal with this learned
tokenization
called gradient-based sub-word
tokenization
or short gbst so gbst
is to find suitable representations of
spans of characters to then pass them on
together to the transformer here in the
visualization a vector is denoted just
by
x1 gbst takes the character sequence and
their byte representation
and forms character blocks a little like
engrams so first are the one grams
there the block size is one then we have
the two character blocks
three character blocks and so on
and gbsd computes a representation for
each block
by mean pooling the representation of
each character in each block
miss coffeebean didn't we say that we
want to reduce the sequence length
now we have four sequences instead of
one
and by mean pooling we lost the order of
the individual characters for block
sizes bigger than one what are we even
doing
ah the recipe goes further in order to
avoid losing the order
by mean pooling the authors add
positional embeddings
which are encoding the order of
characters
in the blocks okay problem solved
are we going to reduce the length now
note that for
bigger block sizes we have fewer vectors
than the number of characters
so the mean pooled representation of
each block is repeated
now such that every character has one
vector assigned to it
so here x1 equals x2 because x2 is just
copied from x1 for the two grams or two
blocks
now the idea is to get a new better
representation for each character
one way to do it is by hard selection by
choosing
one representation from all the four
possibilities and to
throw away the rest but the authors
proposed
soft selection by a weighted sum of
all block representations the weights
here
in other words the scorings are learned
it is the only part in this tokenizer
that
is learned through sgd on the task and
its data
it kind of makes sense that this part is
learned unlike the
other parts where mean pooling is hard
coded because
for getting sensible important scores
from the vectors they first have to be
adapted to the data so we now have a new
representation for each character being
the weighted sum
of the block representations so wait a
minute
what just happened here well in simple
words
gbst basically asks what does
each character need from its fellow
characters to inform its representation
and what if each other character can
choose between
1 gram information 2 gram 3 gram and so
on
or even better each character has the
option to do a combination of 1 gram 2
gram information
in order to determine how much they
should be combined
a transformation is learned to determine
these importances
the gradient updates will tell the
linear transformation responsible for
computing the scores how much scoring is
needed it is
almost like a tension with the only
difference
that each block position is uninformed
about
what the other positions do and how they
combine
things so now similarly to the mlp mixer
or the f net which
is the fourier transform transformer
we have first mixed the characters among
each other by neighborhood
then we mix again but this time
orthogonal to the first mixing
i honestly did not expect to find any
parallel between the mlp mixer
and the char former but here it is and
now we have as many representations
as characters well not yay
because we started with l characters and
their raw representations
and now we still have l character
representations which are
now more informed yes but didn't we say
that we want to reduce the sequence
length
yes we did and this is the final step of
gbst
down sampling these new l learned
character
representations are downsampled again by
a mean pooling operation over
neighboring representations
and this is again hard coded not learned
the only
learnable step in this gbst tokenizer is
the scoring of the character
engram representation wow so is the
tokenization procedure elegant
what do you think well we honestly don't
know
does it have to be elegant mixing
is all you need the mixing does not even
have to be learned
as we saw in the fourier transform
transformer
and in other previous videos any mixing
and that's what
these authors also do often hard-coded
seems to work with transformers so was
this long road of
character representation mixing worth it
yes it kind of was these new
representations from gbst
are ready to be fed into your favorite
transformers
especially because very little aspects
in gbst
are learned optimization will not waste
a lot of time on the tokenizer part
also the tokenizer reduces the sequence
length making the transformer downstream
also faster
i guess you can convince yourself on the
performance of the char former on the
tables in the paper
link below terformer is sometimes
superior
sometimes on par with state-of-the-art
character level models on
glue also this approach works well in
multilingual settings and also on noisy
text where hard-coded tokenization
is brittle usually this good performance
is somewhat expected because
now the tokenization adapts to your data
set and task while not blowing
up your sequence length and 0.1 percent
state-of-the-art up and down
is less important for miss coffee bean
than the flexibility of the transformer
on all the other applications rather
than glue
so yeah i guess that this paper even
though
framed differently from the mlp mixer or
the transformer replacing self-attention
with convolutions or the fourier
transform transformer
is again showing that mixing
representations somehow
almost anyhow works as long as you have
a transformer-like architecture in
general downstream
and yes by this we mean that
self-attention is not essential for
transformers
see this video linked below for more
about that
but this whole mixing right this reminds
us of something this coffee bean
what was it ah yes
you know those times of feature
engineering long gone
now i guess it's time for mixing
engineering
cheers to that miss coffee bean what are
you doing
miss with coffee bean no i thought we
were friends again
no miss coffee bean